when it comes to photo friendly moments
in space
china is on a roll taikonauts leo bo
ming and tang hong bo have completed the
first space walk
from the new station being built in low
earth orbit
a construction site with a view the
mission is the first of eleven needed to
finish construction of the station
as one of the taikonauts that went out
of the core module for the first time
i want to thank all the scientists
involved and thank all chinese people
for your support
there will be more space walks and the
space station will keep growing
thank you liu got around on a mechanical
arm which took him where he needed to go
robotic arms are key to future plans for
smart manufacturing in space
tong hong bo took a more traditional
route along the guard rails
these space walks last about seven hours
it's only the second time a chinese crew
has entered the vacuum of space
the last spacewalk in 2008 lasted just
20 minutes
the tianha station should be completed
next year
the crew members will spend three months
helping build the station conducting
experiments while at the same time
maintaining their fitness
they'll also be capturing views that
chinese astronauts have been unable to
see for themselves
since the u.s locked them out of the
international space station
10 years ago andrew chappelle al jazeera